have you seen this um this new uh
there's like this new program
that it like will it's like AI generated
have you seen it or you could like tell
it to write you an essay or a song or
whatever and it'll write it within
seconds so you could be like
write a song about
my day on the bus and then it'll just
write like a it or I know I know they
have an AI for every for everything
though but I mean that's just it's
[ __ ] sketch that's that's not that's
let's see there you go let's check this
out man look
huh
you're not what a time to be alive would
you buy a Tesla robot for your house to
like help you around like you know like
maybe like a a butler I would not not a
Tesla one no no I would not I I like
when I go when I go to stores I like to
I like to I don't like to self-check out
I like to deal with people when I when I
talk on the phone I ask for the operator
I hit zero over and over and over and
over representative representative
customer service customer operator I
don't I like to deal with people that's
just me I and listen no for sure that's
the most frustrating [ __ ] is when you
call somebody right you know talk to a
human being about something yeah you
could use our self-automated system yeah
like nah I mean and guess what you know
that's the future that's technology we
can't
right can't hide from me can't run from
it but you know that's just me you know
it's [ __ ] to me some of the [ __ ]
they're talking about yeah
how is it we've made all these movies
that are a warning of what happens if we
go down this path too much did nobody
watch these [ __ ] movies
turn into this [ __ ] up like what is
happening like nobody saw a [ __ ]
Terminator or iRobot like what the [ __ ]
is going on with these people
so you're not getting the neural link
chip no yeah
you think Elon could be alien they say
like Terminator was I think Terminator
was the prequel of the Matrix I think
[ __ ] I didn't hear that yeah they're
looking at that uh now I'm gonna say
that out and watch all of them I had to
say that out loud in mind yeah we'll go
ahead yeah
yeah I think if we're talking about
aliens if anybody is kind of an alien
it's probably Elon Musk oh yeah Elon is
yeah he's a he's an interesting cat yeah
yeah Elon if you're watching this man
yeah just I just I just need one b
just give me one man I just please I rap
really well check out my album wait what
did you say you need 1B what is that a
billion oh a billion okay just just
throw me one man you got you got plenty
just I mean he said he said a lot on my
new album and Twitter check out my new
album man Herbert is out now man it's
very personal you know what I'm saying I
put everything I had into it I just need
one billion man just look out for your
boy man